voilà un rapport publié lundi provenant
du haut conseil à l'égalité femme homme
qui risque de faire parler un rapport
qui dénonce les émissions de télé
réalité comme pourvoyeuse de sexisme
parmi les émissions visés par ce rapport
on retrouve notamment les marseillais
versus le reste du monde les anges de la
télé réalité mais aussi plus surprenant
l'émission koh lanta à l'étude de ces
émissions le haut conseil dénonce des
candidats présentés comme des femmes
stupide faible et rival concernant koh
lanta ce sont les plans hyper sexualisée
des candidates qui semble poser problème
une attaque à laquelle alexia laroche
joubert la productrice du programme a
décidé de répondre
depuis quand la réalisation il me semble
que corps plein d'effets sur la côte
basque et les hommes et les femmes bon
papy est très en colère à l'excès
laroche joubert a même demandé un
rendez-vous à marlène schiappa de son
côté mis la star de téléréalité a décidé
elle aussi de réagir à ce rapport dans
des pmp
pour elle il s'agit d'un cliché mois
pour avoir fait le bas cinq cent trente
ans des missions j'ai fait à peu près
neuf émissions en tout j'ai jamais
ressenti un comportement sexiste amant
les gars avant d'ajouter ce qui est
triste malheureusement c'est qu'en fait
on montre qu'un extrait alors qu'en vrai
il faut juger une émission parce qu'en
réalité
alors pour vous ces émissions de
télé-réalité sont-elles sexiste
merci de tout l'affairé marseille
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas fait les marseille à merde ce
fait marseille après quoi j'ai fait
bachar là bien des cas remise et les
anges et vacances desanges du couple
parent c'est moundir et là les
princesses de l'amour elle s'est fait ma
chérie j'étais un peu stressé rassure
toi ça va bien se passer
ben voilà t'inquiète pas y'a pas de
soucis donc un rapport voilà tu as vu au
conseil de l'égalité des femmes et des
hommes qui dit à et 146 pages et
plusieurs émissions mais évidemment les
plus touchés on n'en parlera pas assez
c'est les miss france désolé voilà et la
télé réalité qui dit que les femmes
donnent une image vue pas relaté cet
arrêté de l'image vulgaire des femmes et
des femmes un petit peu idiote
qu'est ce que tu en penses toi est ce
que tu penses que voilà vous faites du
mal à la cause féminine alors déjà pour
moi faut arrêter ce préjugé en disant
qu'ils aient que c'est que les personnes
qui ont des gros seins qui n'ont pas de
cerveau qui font de la télé réalité ce
n'est pas vrai moi je parlais dans mon
cas j'ai vu des mères cette vérité doit
pardon oui jared est moche on est
marseillais c'est mal c'est pas des
marchands à vincent gens qu'on préfère
voir quelqu'un qui a un physique
avantageux mais assez dans tous les
domaines professionnels comme
aujourd'hui va là où on se fait beau on
pour donner la meilleure image de
nous-mêmes d'accord pour revenir au
sujet moi j'ai pas être mon cas moi de
base quand j'ai fait de la télé réalité
ça fait quatre cinq ans que j'en fais je
suis sorti de la fac j'ai j'hésitais pas
la fille la plus jolie du monde à la
javel est dans cet état il ait mené
c'est un sorcier
voilà oui et pourtant ça ne m'a pas
empêché de faire de la télé réalité et
d'être bio chez entendons mais l'idée
que voilà celle ça rend tout ce que vous
faites à la télé way la troisième guerre
mondiale
alone and a est ce que ça donne l'image
un peu la jolie fille se sois belle et
tais toi qui est un peu idiotes dès
qu'elle parlait un peu idiotes marshall
est des gros seins autour d'une piscine
et les idiotes c'est un peu ce qu'on
alors je suis pas d'accord parce que
pour moi lacunes l'alc la culture ça
fait partie de l'un des gens ne savaient
pas comment elle est intelligente c'est
pas parce que tu es cultivé que tu es
intelligent
ce n'est pas parce que tu n'en as pas
que tu l'aies plus une raison séduire
sinon c'est vrai
sinon à la guérilla des ouïes des noms
alors juste un mot dont ceux qui disent
oui effectivement latérite et abîment
l'image de la femme c'est ben oui et
puis je dis pas que les filles qui font
de la télé réalité sont des nanas
oursins complètement idiote mais en tous
les cas la fosse duction s'arrange pour
le faire croire c'est une chose
différente donc ils choisissent quand
même les moments pour faire rire les
gens
c'est si je peux me permettre monsieur
[Rires]
elle voit que c'est un monsieur
voilà alors si je peux la télé a été sa
ville c'est un divertissement c'est
quelque chose d'agréable à regarder pour
oublier son quotidien c'est drôle mais
le drôle n'est pas forcément stupide que
tu penses tu penses que les jeunes
filles qui vous regardent comprennent
que tout ça c'est pour rire elles se
disent pas waouh c'est effectivement il
ya trois guerres mondiales ou h début de
shampoing machin tu penses qu'elle
comprenne que c'est du noir tout noir
pour - oui on peut divertir qui avait
aujourd'hui les gènes déjà déjà pour
avoir pour influencer pour mal influencé
les jeunes il n'y a pas que la télé
réalité
il ya d'autres choses paraître de dire
que ça que la télé réalité qui donnent
une mauvaise image alors que je peux
dire c'est que les rapports avant
d'abord avoir juste quel est le rapport
par exemple la pression sur les femmes
et la question du consentement dans
l'altérité se pose que ce soit en bikini
dans la maison en peignoir transparent
un talon aiguille au petit déjeuner dans
la salle commune la télé rites et montre
au public des femmes sexualisé dans des
comprenant des contacts qui ne s'y prête
pas et ils disent aussi le but affiché
d'élire la plus belle façon dont ça
c'est pour les miss france on a parlé
deux fois mais voilà grosso modo c'est
ça les hommes sont mieux traités est ce
que les alors y annonçaient de graves
d'eau dans l'espace bien sûr c'est que
les hommes ça se casse tête pour être
beau est-ce qu'ils sont pas tous barman
et est pour bientôt qui sont cultivés
pas plus sûr juste beau sont là pour
décorer aussi ouais c'est pas plus les
hommes que les femmes
ils sont beaux et catherine qui
évidemment est très remonté sur le sujet
katrina pas ministre
moi je suis d'accord avec ce qu'elle dit
c'est pas parce qu'il ya ce qu'elle est
ce qu est ce que la télé montre il faut
savoir qu'ils sont filmés 24 heures sur
24 que point émission bien sûr on fait
un montage et comprend les épisodes des
plus croustillants oui je me sens
ridicule soit ils s'engueulent
donc c'est là c'est là dessus qu'on juge
demeurer station et l'image positive
négative je fais parler deux secondes
donc effectivement ce ça ça donne une
mauvaise image des femmes
c'est vrai même si c'est faux
deuxièmement ce qu au conseil se
trompent de combat
parce que le combat sera de cibler des
émissions quoi qu'on en pense de
latérite et des miss france c'est de
cibler les réalités des salaires dans
les médias la visibilité des femmes
c'est ça le combat pas de cibler la
visibilité si c'est pour faire la
visibilité que des filles qui ont des
gros seins qui sont autour de la table
qui sont julie corey la dir et c'est
après ce sera la parole parce que tu est
évidemment tu connais le sujet tu fais
la témérité et je plaisante mais fait
que vous voilà au bout c'est vous soyez
intelligents et pour vous voilà vous
savez faire du buzz il n'y a pas de
souci c'est pas ta mais quand même
l'image dégradante de la femme c'est que
quand on garde cet c'était les réalités
on a l'impression que même à 20 ans on
et botoxée avec un gros ça que quand
vous sortez moi je sais je regarde
beaucoup par mon métier de la télé
réalité toutes les nanas et sortent avec
des trucs je suis désolé c'est pas là
l'image la plus claire et la plus
naturelle de la face et des images de
femmes qu'elles cèdent pas tout
simplement j'aimerais que tu répondes
lamela nike est avec nous même si on a
la journée ces boîtes mails en deuil
avec nous
toutes les jeunes filles et j'en
croisais beaucoup pardon j'ai fait le
terreau était pas les anges de la télé
réalité le mag
et c'est vrai que jouer toutes ces
gamines de 20 ans qui pensais
qu'aujourd'hui pour être une jeune fille
fallait un sac dior vuitton j'ai pas
droite et tout mais à lui son absence
d'aucune exception
à 22 ans était botoxée de la cible pour
te remonter ça une bouche comme ça et
penser qu'aujourd'hui il aurait voulu
vous semblez vous le fasse et c'est
votre choix n'y a pas de soucis temps je
suis d'accord avec moi à charleston
l'image à la jeune fille je trouve qu
alors voilà du coup double décourager
l'achat et c'est maintenant une
trentaine à allaiter pour moi on ya bien
beaucoup de filles de différents profit
je suis d'accord un défi qui sont
refaites ya des faits aussi qui sont
naturellement il y en a beaucoup mais le
truc c'est que voilà moi personnellement
j'ai fait de la chirurgie est chic et je
dis merci à moncheaux genre je ne
sentais pas belle
j'ai fait la chose jugée parce que je
vous laisse regarder quelqu'un est
aujourd'hui comme les parents qui font
l'appel de a été arrêté ils ont les
moyens de bien se paie cash les études
vous sentir plus joli plus désirable et
pour avoir plus confiance parce que
justement elles sont sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'elle se prenne plein de trucs
dans la tronche et que du coup des fois
elles sont souvent dans l'excès alors
qu'elles se font de la chirurgie c'est
pareil sans jamais renier d'autres
aurélie est une autre personne à
personne à temps opportun de magali que
mes sujets et mathieu moi ce rapport
c'est un leurre c'est juste dévier le
problème là où français devient un
problème pourquoi parce que le sexisme
pour moi ce rapport c'est sexy les sexy
c'est vrai il se dirige vers la femme
alors que la téléréalité et toutes les
autres émissions il ya autant de femmes
que d'hommes s'est équilibré ils ont les
mêmes droits
on demande pas aux femmes de jouer les
débiles je pense que mélanie paul thème
on peut le dire me l'a dit on leur a
jamais demandé de jouer la débile
elles sont comme elles sont c'est juste
le reflet de la société la téléralité
ces noms de tous les niveaux d'accord
mais la nuit à la base elle est quand
même notaire d'accord on a tous les
niveaux aujourd'hui une affronter les
réalités il y a des cils qui sont
refaites défis qui sont pas du tour fait
défis qui sont pour la chirurgie défis
qui sont contre la chirurgie et je vais
te donner un exemple bien précis et ça
vous ne relevez pas donc vous relever
les choses quand ça vous arrange mais
vous n'avez pas relevé par exemple
camilla kamina qui est une candidate de
secret story d'accord qui est la femme
du gagnant tier du dernier secretstory
n'aurait qui a participé à moundir qui
refuse de se mettre en maillot de bain
qui a fait tout le prix
ram en combi-short d'accord la
production l'a acceptée elle a été
montrée en combi-short elle ne s'est pas
montré une seule fois en maillot de bain
et ça ne lui a pas posé de problème à
imposer aucun femme à la production ni à
la chaîne
et ça personne ne l'a vu et personne n'a
dit parler mathieu a juste rappelé une
chose les règles les règles elles sont
sorties de ce jeu là au printemps 2001
loft story 1 sur m6 on se rappelle le
qu' une personne
loana est partielle à gagner non me
correspondait au physique qui faisait
qu'on a des comptes sonate toutes des
petites soeurs de loana finalement les
horizons gagnon l'alcool pur souche at
on dit c'est une question mélanie je
viens d'apprendre que tu es notaire
talons qu'elle maîtrise de moins de
droits en faveur de landreau impérial
j'ai fait deux ans sa légèreté hassan
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
mais ni d'une fouille entreprise conçu
un diplôme pareil et que du coup tu vas
dans les émissions qui font de toi
forcément un peu une caricature quelle
est la suite possible tu vois ce que
j'ai à ce que tu t'es pas tu es derrière
à part effectivement devenir influence
eux de refaire les jeunes elle fera que
dans un cadre privé c'est comme vous
vous êtes ici au travail vous n'êtes pas
le même que dans votre vie familiale et
sentimentale et amicale ces deux choses
complètement différentes
donc pour toi donc quand on est bien
d'accord que pour toi la télé réalité ne
donne pas une image sexiste et le de ne
pas nous y invite de la femme là ont
fondu enchaîné on n'est pas en train de
juger du respect des gens qui sont dans
la télé réalité c'est la face et ce
combo mariam ou sajoo vous entendu un
mot dur d'un mode c'est bon on y va je
produis beaucoup d'émissions de
télévision et si j'avais à produire des
émissions de télé réalité je prendrai
des personnalités comme la sienne c'est
à dire que des caricatures des
caricatures ici en fasse trop parce
qu'on l'aimé en bain en maillot au bord
d'une piscine n'est pas à la montagne
mais des cols roulés on veut qu'elle
soit un peu conne elle font exprès elle
joue le jeu elle faute ou alors elles
sont un autre